Hey guys for this video I brought you out to Hawaii because
apparently I'm on vacation.
So while we're here, I teamed up with a company called LifeVantage
to tell you about a new product they just developed
and to share with you my ten favorite life hacks for
when you're down at the beach.
Let's jump right in.
When you pull up to the beach it's not alway convenient
to take your car keys with you, but you wont find lockers
at the beach and you can't take your keys with you in the ocean
either, so what do you do?
Try looping a long sturdy blade of grass through your keychain, tying
it off to form a ring.
Then press the loop into one of the top treads of
your tire, holding it in place with a small pebble.
Flip the keys back so they dangle behind the tire
and they'll be out of sight, out of mind, and off the ground as well.
So they won't get exposed to moisture if it rains while you are gone.
Now if you are in a hurry and don't have the time or patience
to jury-rig a hook, you could simply toss your keys
behind one of your tires instead.
I've been using this trick for years,
and as long as you do it discreetly, no one will have any idea your keys are even back there.
So go have fun! Play without the worry of losing or destroying your keys at the beach.
because when you come back, you should find they're stashed exactly where you left them.
The next time you want to go snorkeling
but don't have a safe place for your phone, keys, and cash,
you can use a clean baby diaper to stash all your valuables instead.
Use the sticky tabs to hold the bundle together,
and to the untrained eye, it's just a used diaper that nobody wants to touch.
By the way, if you set it down next to your towel and flip-flops,
it'll be a lot less likely to get thrown away by accident.
Now if you want to go one step further,
try opening a pack of chocolate spread and rubbing some along the inside flap of the diaper.
This will make your decoy diaper look authentically used
and should be enough to discourage any would-be beach thieves
from finding your stuff.
Have you ever stopped to unravel a poopy diaper lying at the beach?
Of course you haven't! And nobody else will either.
To prove this point, I left mine exposed and unattended for over an hour,
and when I came back, everything was exactly the way it was when I left it.
When you're bodysurfing, splashing in the waves, or out for a little swim,
you may suddenly notice that your ears don't feel normal anymore.
The feeling of water trapped in your ears is uncomfortable, and makes it difficult to hear.
Point the affected ear to the ground and jump up and down with a few sharp jolts.
You should hear the water tension break and clear out almost instantly.
The key here is in the sudden jolts at the end.
Do the same thing with the other ear, and you should feel cleared up and back to normal as easy as that.
Now some people suggest that blowing up a balloon will have the exact same effect.
So I gave that method a try as well,
but without any success at all.
It is a nice idea, but I don't think it actually works.
When you're out snorkeling or diving to the bottom of the ocean,
you're going to see some really amazing things, but your ears are going to start hurting like crazy as well.
This is because the air in your head is being compressed.
Plug your nose, and gently blow into it as you do.
This will force air into your eustachian tubes and help equalize the pressure
so you can dive down even further without pain, and without causing any damage.
Walking around barefoot on a sandy beach is very relaxing,
but you're quickly going to find the bottoms of your feet
get caked in a very fine sand that nothing seems to remove
and that's frustrating.
Here's what you do.
Load up a rag with a pile of baby powder right in the center.
Then use string or rubber bands to tie it into a ball
and you've just created a super sand remover that will seem to work miracles.
Tap it to your skin and it releases
moisture-absorbing powder and prevents any new sand from sticking in its place.
So, when it's time to head back to the car,
just sit down, brush off your feet a bit, and give your skin a little rub.
Like magic, the grains of sand all slide off with ease
leaving your feet feeling silky, smooth, and sand-free.
This also works on arms, legs, and even the tops of your sandals as well
so, no more problems with sticky, irritating, and stubborn sand.
You can avoid getting water and sand in your phone
by dropping it into a clear plastic sandwich bag and sealing it up airtight.
This beefs up your phone's resistance to the elements
but still allows you to text, watch videos, and even make phone calls as well.
If you open a small gap in one of the corners of your sandwich bag and suck the air out,
it will create a vacuum seal around your phone that can act as an improvised water-proof case.
Zip up the seal airtight again,
and you've got a make-shift underwater video camera
that you can use to check out the open ocean around you
but do it at your own risk.
Nothing's worse than being sick when you're on vacation,
so before you actually get sick,
try adding a pinch of salt and baking soda to a cup of water
to give your sinuses a rinse.
Pour the mixture into one of your nostrils,
and it will fill up your sinuses completely
to the point where it starts flowing freely out the other side.
It looks and feels incredibly bizarre,
but it helps wash away pollen, bacteria,
and any other irritants festering up inside
before they become a problem.
It is a real technique and it really does work,
and it just might help with the quality of your next vacation.
Some experts suggest that by lowering your stress levels,
you actually have a better chance of living a longer, happier life,
and the people at LifeVantage agree.
LifeVantage is a company that some people say
is at the forefront of nutrigenomics,
and apparently they're successfully bio-hacking the aging process as well.
Their new line of Protandim synergizers
are designed to improve health on a cellular level
and help redefine the aging of our cells.
The Protandim nrf2 synergizer
is LifeVantage's original nutrigenomic breakthrough
designed to fight oxidative stress which is the
main biochemical effect of aging on our cells.
And their Protandim NRF1 synergizer
prevents the decline of mitochondria in the cells,
which helps reduce the second biochemical effect of aging as well.
When these two products are taken together,
they provide a viable way to reduce cellular stress
which could lead to a longer, healthier life
resulting in more time you could be spending at the beach.
So there you have it, guys!
Ten awesome life hacks that you can
use the next time you're down at the beach.
Huge shout out to LifeVantage for reaching out and sponsoring this video.
If you want to learn more about nutrigenomics and the Protandim synergizers,
then click the link in the description to find out what they can do for you.
In the meantime, thanks for joining me for this video
and I'll be looking for you in the next one!
Talk to you then.